yeah we do try our women the best here
dude no that's like look at how we
praise them you know what i mean like
when this guy saw his favorite
congresswoman well look look this guy
asc my favorite big booty latina i love
you aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
i love it my favorite aoc nice to meet
you look how sexy she looks in that
dress that sucks
i love it aoc
hot like a tamale
i mean the last line is kind of funny
the last line is objectively [ __ ]
yeah yeah but uh yeah he's he's a
[ __ ] weirdo yeah dude [ __ ] that yeah
megan kelly was defending this dude like
crazy this guy i did megan's podcast i
love megan shout out megan megan's
[ __ ] hilarious and she got a hunk of
a husband see if you can get up meg and
kelly's husband i'd talk to him like
that 100
but uh but uh but yeah she was just like
he's just joking he's just having some
fun like when did we become so sensitive
and i was like man
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's crossing the line of it yeah when
they're there it feels a lot like
harassment yeah it is weird when they're
there is different you're just heckling
on the street yeah it's weird it's like
you're doing something you're making a
girl feel uncomfortable and you're not
doing it because you want to hit on her
it would actually be less weird if you
would go go go yes it would be less
weird if you were doing it sexually hey
i want to be with you like if your
intention was to get her number yeah if
you're like oh my god you're my favorite
big bully latina god damn you're so
beautiful hold on hold on let me talk
can i take you out for dinner please i
love you [ __ ] great point his intent
was to make her feel uncomfortable yeah
and
that shines through it's very obvious
yes and as an american who protects
women and we treat women the best at any
place in the entire world that's right
dude i have to reject this because that
was un-american
that was french that was un-american
that's very fresh friendship that was
somewhere
i know that we don't treat women like
that here to their face
yeah you like you said we can
objectively
talk about a woman's body i don't even
think her ass is the best part of her
body this guy clearly is not familiar
with latinas
or it's from a place where they're
predominantly mexicans and they're built
like a [ __ ] back of shifty's head
right
what guys
what what what's your favorite part of
aoc
her mind her brain
her smile yeah i like her mind okay i'm
into her mind
yeah what's your favorite thing that
she's ever said like
what's your favorite like thought of
hers like she said something you were
like wow i'm really attracted to this
woman's brain no she was fighting for
the working class and her huge [ __ ]
fact
you know
but she was she was fighting for the
working class and waiting for you and
you're a socialist bro say again you're
a socialist i when it comes to women's
issues i'm assuming yeah yes when it
comes to
women's bodies i'm a socialist trying to
seize the means of reproduction let's go
baby i see you
did you see what he just did right there
he just i was in next i mean if we were
talking about communism that would be
like next level joke but that was a good
joke right yeah yeah yeah
i mean like
seize the
bed yeah he's a closeted marxist just
because i delayed it
yeah yeah that was a next level joke
thank you seize the means of
reproduction now technically that would
make me a conservative though why
because you're trying to grab them by
the [ __ ] no
conservatives are trying to seize the
means of reproduction which is the most
commonest thing that's actually a funny
spin
why are you being so communist what do
you mean well you're trying to seize the
means of reproduction yeah wow that'd be
a smart spin but they wouldn't get it
because i'm barely getting it
mark can you explain it with your gay
things
miles
pro-life chariot oh that was good that
was good look at us we're firing on all
cylinders happening bro it's really
happening